bienvenue à la plaine des cafres le
décor est magnifique mais le travail est
rude
les producteurs d'oignons pays se bat
chaque jour pour exister face à
l'importation et où commencent les mains
dans la terre
[Musique]
voilà la base de notre alimentation est
pourtant sur 8500 tonnes d'oignons
consommer localement
sept mille cinq cents hommes sont
importés et seulement 800 tonnes
produites dans l'île alors comment
sauver le nom pays en développement les
filières courtes violent grondin fait
partie de ces irréductibles
depuis cinq ans ils produisent en
famille 4 à 5 tonnes par an comme thème
l'oignon qui fait qu'elle a envie de
faire et trêve c'est comme tout métier
un moment donné on se lance des défis et
puis l'oignon permet aussi aux terrains
de revenus il ya là avec la pomme de
terre on peut faire on peut faire la
même chose si on n'a pas de grosses
grosses pour recel on va dire bon
vicieux l'oignon comme nous on est
diversifiée ça permet de proposer à nos
clients un produit supplémentaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce mandat en 2007 a bénéficié d'une aide
département sur onze productions
notamment ici à une seconde 1 c'est sur
l'ognon dont il a bénéficié de 8000
euros en fait un dead
l'objectif en fait de cette
départementale c'est d'augmenter de plus
en plus la quantité de fruits et légumes
sur la réunion il connaît les paroles
importations les oignons
il permet nous un tel un petit peu
commune compétitif voilà s'il ya de
l'oignon pays
le l'oignon de réadaptation il va
toujours se mettre en dessous nous mais
si y'a pas l'onu le pays
l'oignon de2 il n'y a pas dit il va
monter alors monsieur yves ya lieu une
montagne le document comme quoi les
produits éligibles
et puis comme moi comment on y fait de
l'oignon hamiti famille vous prend
l'oignon sait on ce produit nous avons
encore une marge de manoeuvre
ici à la réunion nous avons une grosse
marge par rapport à l'import nous
pouvons aujourd'hui aider les animateurs
à mieux produire et aussi permettre à
nos consommateurs de mieux consommer le
but du jeu c'est un respect un
partenariat gagnant gagnant
[Musique]
et la clé de la réussite reste le
travail partenarial une intelligence
collective pour le bien de la filière
une très bonne a complètement manque des
pièces le monsieur là où lâchant me
confond le partenariat c'est ça qui va
permettre à l'agriculture d'avancé un
vrai partenariat
ce qui intéresse c'est que nous mettons
en place une aide n'est pas que
financière c'est une oeuvre à la fois
technique
c'est une aide qui va permettre d'avoir
des bonnes pratiques et peut être aussi
de tendre de plus en plus notamment vers
de la production raisonnée biowatt en
fait changé du dognon oui manger des
oignons puis c'est un jeu je conseille
aux consommateurs de consommer local
mieux le corps
[Musique]